Shure: 嘎嘎香
Katrina: 然后还要干什么
Katrina: So what do we do next?
Shure: 然后烧炭就可以起锅
Shure: Then we just need to burn the charcoal to start cooking.
Katrina: 烧炭
Katrina: Burn the charcoal.
Shure: 开始一会我不知道
Shure: Start for a while, I'm not sure.
Shure: 这个咸淡我有点掌握不好
Shure: 然后一会如果淡了
Shure: If it's too bland later,
Shure: 就直接就是巨大的面团啊
Shure: it'll just be a huge dough.
Jake:这是什么肉啊
Jake: What kind of meat is this?
Jake:这都牛肉和鸡肉
Jake: It's all beef and chicken.
Shure: 这全是牛肉
Shure: It's all beef.
Shure: 然后这是鸡肉和排骨
Shure: And this is chicken and ribs.
Jake:哟看起来很厉害
Jake: Wow, it looks impressive.
Shure: 绝绝对香
Shure: It's absolutely delicious.
Shure: 跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you,
Shure: 一般不来长春都尝不到这手艺的
Shure: you won't find this kind of skill outside of Changchun.
Alice:酸啊
Alice: It's sour.
Shure: 今儿是偷偷漏抖都给你们了
Shure: Today, I'm secretly sharing this with you all.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 是烤的话是要在外面烤吗
Lucia: If it's grilling, do we need to do it outside?
Shure: 这比我女朋友都早
Shure: This is even earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:对那边有个好家
Jake: Yes, there's a good place over there.
Shure: 迟了两周
Shure: Two weeks late.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Jake:啊早谁谁早吃那两周啊
Jake: Ah, who ate those two weeks early?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 比我女朋友
Shure: Earlier than my girlfriend.
Jake:他还没吃
Jake: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 那我们周日是还要弄这些是吗
Shure: So, we need to do these again on Sunday, right?
Jake:对周日还要弄
Jake: Yes, we need to do it on Sunday.
Shure: 啊那应该也能吃
Shure: Ah, then we should be able to eat.
Alice:周日不是不吃饭吗
Alice: Don't we fast on Sundays?
Alice:就是加冰
Alice: Just add ice.
Jake:这烤烤一点
Jake: Grill a bit.
Katrina: 好一点
Katrina: That's better.
Alice:哦提前搞一点
Alice: Oh, let's get some done in advance.
Katrina: 好一
Katrina: Okay, got it.
Shure: 意思一下懂了吧
Shure: Just a little gesture, got it?
Jake:你的意思一下
Jake: Your little gesture.
Jake:或者剩一点给他哈哈哈
Jake: Or leave a bit for him, hahaha.
Lucia: 这外头除了那圈墙
Lucia: Outside, besides that wall.
Alice:啊剩一点
Alice: Ah, leave a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈真嘟假嘟
Alice: Hahaha, real or fake?
Lucia: 外头是不除了那圈墙灯没有别的灯了
Lucia: Outside, besides that wall light, there's no other light.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:就是这5个灯
Jake: Just these 5 lights.
Jake:我我可以去打光
Jake: I can go light it up.
Jake:就是你要什么灯吗
Jake: Do you need any lights?
Lucia: 哦没有没有
Lucia: Oh no, no.
Lucia: 不是我是说如果要在外面烤的话
Lucia: No, I mean if we want to grill outside.
Lucia: 外面其实还有点黑
Lucia: It's actually quite dark outside.
Jake:啊对没关系
Jake: Ah, it's okay.
Alice:火一点起来应该好一点吧
Alice: If the fire is up, it should be better.
Jake:这氛围到位了
Jake: The ambiance is set.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 但是只有那个就是炉子那里会亮一点
Lucia: But only the stove area will be bright.
Lucia: 咱们吃饭的桌子还挺黑的啊
Lucia: The dining table is still quite dark.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不过有那个那个影棚灯
Lucia: But there's that studio light.
Alice:先找点纸盒点火吧
Alice: Let's get some cardboard to light the fire first.
Alice:还是有火枪啥的
Alice: Or is there a torch or something?
Shure: 没事
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 呃我想想我下一步要
Shure: Uh, let me think about what I need to do next.
Shure: 做什么呃
Shure: What to do next, uh.
Shure: 这些也可以拿出来
Shure: These can also be taken out.
Shure: 羊排
Shure: Lamb chops.
Shure: 大蒜都拿着吃
Shure: Eat garlic with them.
Shure: 肉不吃蒜香味少一半呢
Shure: Meat without garlic loses half its flavor.
Alice:你今天晚上想吃这个吗
Alice: Do you want to eat this tonight?
Alice:那我们打开吧
Alice: Then let's open it.
Lucia: 可以吃好的
Lucia: It's good to eat.
Alice:这个蜂蜜给你
Alice: Here's the honey for you.
Lucia: 哦你不你不用这个行
Lucia: Oh, you don't need it? Okay.
Jake:大师我们做什么呀
Jake: Master, what should we do?
Alice:我不吃蜂蜜的
Alice: I don't eat honey.
Shure: 大师
Shure: Master.
Alice:大师你要蒜吗
Alice: Master, do you want garlic?
Shure: 不是别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 大师蒜拿生吃的
Shure: Master eats garlic raw.
Tasha: 不要
Tasha: No.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 对然后把把生菜洗了吧
Shure: Okay, then wash the lettuce.
Shure: 来个人把生菜洗了
Shure: Someone wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 生吃大蒜
Lucia: Eating raw garlic.
Jake:生菜
Jake: Lettuce.
Shure: 没吃过吧
Shure: Haven't tried it, right?
Shure: 尝尝就知道了
Shure: Try it, you'll see.
Lucia: 可以生吃而且就是跟肉在一起
Lucia: You can eat it raw, especially with meat.
Tasha: 我知道了但
Tasha: I know, but...
Jake:怎么洗
Jake: How do you wash it?
Shure: 生生菜就是洗洗菜
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 挺好吃的
Lucia: It's pretty tasty.
Lucia: 只不过就是吃完之后会有蒜味
Lucia: But you'll have garlic breath afterward.
Shure: 咋洗他咋洗知道不
Shure: Do you know how to wash it?
Shure: 拿个盆装里面
Shure: Put it in a basin.
Shure: 然后把生菜洗了
Shure: And then wash the lettuce.
Lucia: 所以一般很少这样
Lucia: So, we rarely do that.
Jake:干哈干哈干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:咱要干嘛
Jake: What are we doing?
Shure: 就是把生菜洗
Shure: Just wash the lettuce.
Jake:洗洗生菜
Jake: Wash the lettuce.
Shure: 就剩生菜没洗了啊
Shure: Only the lettuce is left unwashed.
Shure: 那个土豆
Shure: The potatoes...
Alice:生菜没洗
Alice: The lettuce isn't washed.
Shure: 土豆想吃的话就削了
Shure: If you want to eat potatoes, peel them.
Shure: 然后切成片
Shure: Then slice them.
Alice:开开瓶
Alice: Open the bottle.
Jake:行啊
Jake: Sure.
Katrina: 好了麻烦你们起一下这个
Katrina: Okay, could you please get this?
Alice:我没有盆吗
Alice: Do I have a basin?
Jake:没有吧
Jake: No, I don't think so.
Jake:这锅怎么长这样这锅怎么长这样
Jake: Why does this pot look like this? Why does it look like this?
Alice:有人要纯酸奶吗
Alice: Does anyone want plain yogurt?
Alice:比较酸的
Alice: It's quite sour.
Jake:这锅为什么长成这个样子
Jake: Why does this pot look like this?
Jake:可以吃可以吃
Jake: It's edible, it's edible.
Lucia: 嗯那就3个
Lucia: Hmm, then let's have three.
Alice:纯酸奶无糖的好
Alice: Pure yogurt without sugar is best.
Jake:嗯可以吃
Jake: Yeah, it's edible.
Tasha: 好没事
Tasha: Okay, no problem.
Lucia: 没事我可以把这个蜂蜜分享给你
Lucia: No problem, I can share this honey with you.
Alice:还有人吗还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else? Anyone else?
Lucia: 白砂糖也可以加
Lucia: You can also add white sugar.
Tasha: 其实还有人吗
Tasha: Actually, is there anyone else?
Alice:还有人吗
Alice: Anyone else?
Jake:好
Alice:微微你是纯酸奶吗
Alice: Tasha, do you want pure yogurt?
Jake:我给你清掉这个东西
Jake: I'll clean this up for you.
Alice:那我们3个
Alice: Then the three of us.
Lucia: 行那我拿两个碗
Lucia: Alright, I'll get two bowls.
Lucia: 正好我刚洗完
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Uh-huh.
Shure: 这也没放油
Shure: There's no oil in it.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: Just remembered.
Jake:发生什么事
Jake: What happened?
Shure: 是吧是没放油吧再倒点
Shure: Right? There's no oil, let's add some more.
Shure: 你看看不行了吧
Shure: Look, it's not working, is it?
Lucia: 我把我把手再冲一下去
Lucia: I'll go rinse my hands again.
Alice:不放油也行吧
Alice: It's fine without oil, right?
Lucia: 我刚抓了那个生蚝袋子
Lucia: I just handled that bag of oysters.
Shure: 不不行不行
Shure: No, no, it's not fine.
Shure: 得放下去
Shure: We need to add it.
Alice:你考的时候不是也要刷他吗
Alice: Don't you brush it when you grill it?
Shure: 不刷不刷
Shure: No, no brushing.
Shure: 直接烤
Shure: Just grill it directly.
Alice:不刷呦
Alice: No brushing, huh?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 拿筷子别上手了
Shure: Use chopsticks, don't use your hands.
Shure: 让你偷学
Shure: Stealing my techniques.
Shure: 你都不学全了
Shure: And you didn't even learn them completely.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后到时候出去骂教的不对退钱
Shure: Then you'll go out and blame the teacher, asking for a refund.
Katrina: 哈到时候出去别说我是修硕学生
Katrina: Haha, when we go out, don't tell anyone I'm Shure's student.
Katrina: 我要放歌
Katrina: I want to play some music.
Shure: 放吧把我电脑拿来吧
Shure: Go ahead, bring my computer.
Shure: 进去拿就行
Shure: Just go in and get it.
Shure: 应该没有你什么不能看的吧
Shure: There shouldn't be anything you can't see, right?
Shure: 闭着眼睛进去吧
Shure: Just close your eyes and go in.
Shure: 哈哈哈有
Shure: Hahaha, there is.
Katrina: 不稀罕看
Shure: 密码吗有
Shure: Password? Yes, there is.
Jake:钢丝球是我瞎还是不在这
Lucia: 是好像是不在这
Lucia: It doesn't seem to be here.
Jake:是我是是不在这OK
Jake: Yeah, it's not here. OK.
Jake:总觉得我看到了又没看到
Jake: I keep thinking I saw it but didn't.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Lucia: 你可能是看到了那个就是下水的那个
Lucia: Maybe what you saw was something else.
Katrina: 就怎么用
Katrina: How do I use it?
Katrina: 打开就行是吗
Katrina: Just open it, right?
Shure: 对这个就拧拧它的大小就好
Shure: Yes, just twist it to adjust the size.
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Shure: 随便放吧
Shure: Just play whatever you want.
Katrina: 哦已经连上了哦
Katrina: Oh, it's already connected.
Shure: 对已经连上
Shure: Yes, it's connected.
Katrina: 只要直接插就行
Katrina: Just plug it in directly.
Shure: 插上就行
Shure: Just plug it in.
Tasha: 没有一个地方可以
Tasha: There's nowhere to...
Shure: 往里一点别掉
Shure: Push it in a bit, don't let it fall.
Alice:嗯我给你
Alice: Hmm, let me help you.
Alice:这个芒果今天晚上要吃的
Alice: This mango is for tonight.
Alice:这好像没有勺吧
Alice: Seems like there's no spoon.
Alice:抱歉了
Alice: Sorry about that.
Alice:用这个
Alice: Use this.
Jake:这东西怎么这
Jake: What's with this thing?
Jake:能擦干净吗这
Jake: Can this be cleaned?
Tasha: 不能就算了
Tasha: If not, just forget it.
Alice:是不是有点抽象哈哈哈
Alice: Is it a bit abstract? Hahaha.
Tasha: 火吧
Tasha: Fire it up.
Lucia: 这个不太好弄还是拿个那个
Lucia: This is tricky, better get another one.
Lucia: 中午啊今天中午外卖没给勺
Lucia: At noon, they forgot the spoon with the delivery.
Lucia: 其他的勺还有用吗
Lucia: Are there any other spoons we can use?
Lucia: 咱一会吃的时候得用勺
Lucia: We need spoons for eating later.
Lucia: 一次性餐具还有吗
Lucia: Do we have any disposable cutlery left?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Lucia: 一次那个一次性餐具
Lucia: The disposable cutlery.
Lucia: 因为我们好像没什么勺
Lucia: Because it seems like we don't have many spoons.
Lucia: 然后现在要舀这个
Lucia: And we need to scoop this now.
Alice:我用筷子弄的给你选一个吧
Alice: I can use chopsticks to get one for you.
Jake:哦一次性勺啊
Jake: Oh, you mean disposable spoons.
Lucia: 随便都行
Lucia: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 但是但是
Lucia: But, but...
Lucia: 关键在于
Lucia: The key is...
Lucia: 咱们吃的时候要用勺吃
Lucia: We need spoons to eat.
Alice:我用筷子吧
Alice: I'll use chopsticks.
Jake:咱要不买一点吧
Jake: Should we buy some?
Jake:买个外卖买
Jake: Order takeout and get them with it.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, hahaha.
Jake:不是不是哈哈哈
Jake: No, no, hahaha.
Jake:就是外卖里面有配送这些商品的
Jake: Takeout usually comes with these items.
Alice:给你选一个这
Alice: Let me pick one for you.
Jake:这这这有的选吗
Jake: Is there a choice?
Jake:这个左边
Jake: This one on the left.
Alice:不一样吗
Alice: Is it different?
Tasha: 对啊他写上
Tasha: Yeah, he wrote it.
Jake:对啊那选啥
Jake: Yeah, so what to choose?
Alice:差不多你随便选
Alice: It's similar, pick any.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:这个给你放哪
Alice: Where should I put this for you?
Jake:给我放
Jake: Give it to me.
Tasha: 好了不用擦了洗不掉了
Tasha: Alright, no need to wipe it, it won't come off.
Tasha: 要把水沾到这个
Tasha: You need to get the water on this.
Tasha: 沾到
Tasha: Get it on.
Lucia: 这个蜂蜜是一个勺型的
Lucia: This honey is shaped like a spoon.
Lucia: 所以我我可以用这个蜂蜜勺吃它
Lucia: So I can use this honey spoon to eat it.
Jake:我算洗完了吗
Jake: Am I done washing?
Tasha: 算现在要把它擦干
Tasha: Yes, now you need to dry it.
Tasha: 就是就是
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 擦到看
Tasha: Wipe it until you see...
Alice:无油无水状态
Alice: It's completely oil-free and dry.
Tasha: 啊这个明显还有水
Tasha: Ah, there's clearly still water.
Tasha: 你要拿新的纸再擦一下
Tasha: You need to use a new paper to wipe it again.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你尝一口吗
Jake: Do you want to taste it?
Tasha: 嗯不尝
Tasha: Hmm, no.
Shure: 来借个剪刀把碳打开
Shure: Can I borrow some scissors to open the charcoal?
Tasha: OK啦
Tasha: OK.
Tasha: 这包纸封在这就是专门擦他的
Tasha: This pack of paper is specifically for wiping it.
Jake:哦没看见多少
Jake: Oh, I didn't see much.
Jake:还是瞎了点
Jake: Still a bit blind.
Tasha: 底部就不用擦了里面
Tasha: No need to wipe the bottom, just the inside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:爱擦就是要擦
Jake: Love wiping, so wipe it.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Shure: 来个帮我一起引碳的
Shure: Can someone help me with the charcoal?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Lucia: 我马上我把这个搅好
Lucia: I'll do it soon, just finishing this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Jake:嘿嘿嘿对不起
Jake: Hehe, sorry.
Jake:7秒的记忆
Jake: 7 seconds memory.
Tasha: 人不如鱼系列
Tasha: People worse than fish series.
Jake:怎么样
Jake: How is it?
Jake:锃光瓦亮是不
Jake: Shiny and bright, right?
Alice:是不是得给它弄开啊
Alice: Should we open it up?
Alice:这么大块不好点吧
Alice: Such a big piece won't light up well.
Shure: 应该还行
Shure: Should be fine.
Katrina: YOLO目标检测模型
Katrina: YOLO object detection model.
Tasha: 鸡蛋呢
Tasha: Where are the eggs?
Alice:不太好印
Alice: Hard to print.
Alice:我拿点纸箱
Alice: I'll get some cardboard.
Tasha: 拿3个鸡蛋
Tasha: Get 3 eggs.
Lucia: 我来我离得近
Lucia: I'll get them, I'm closer.
Tasha: 好那你来打吧
Tasha: Okay, you crack them then.
Alice:哦酒精棉是吗
Alice: Oh, alcohol wipes, right?
Lucia: 我害怕我会像那天那样打吗
Lucia: I'm afraid I'll mess up like that day.
Lucia: 你你来打吧要不
Lucia: How about you do it instead?
Alice:干的
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 哦因为你戴着那个手套
Lucia: Oh, because you're wearing gloves.
Lucia: 但是我怕我不会打
Lucia: But I'm afraid I won't get it right.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 就那天不是打错过一次
Lucia: Didn't I mess it up once that day?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Go ahead.
Alice:嗯好臭啊
Alice: Ugh, it stinks.
Tasha: 打这个碗里
Tasha: Crack it into this bowl.
Jake:好人类早期打蛋行为
Jake: Early human egg-cracking behavior.
Tasha: 不要碰到水
Tasha: Don't let it touch the water.
Tasha: 打滴滴滴滴
Tasha: Drip, drip, drip.
Tasha: 再滴再滴
Tasha: Drip some more.
Lucia: 就是小心蛋黄不能破
Lucia: Be careful not to break the yolk.
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Lucia: 第一次就成功了
Lucia: First try success.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
Lucia: 要不还是你来吧
Lucia: Maybe you should do it instead.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我我拿着一个
Lucia: Haha, I'm holding one.
Jake:好看我的成功几个
Jake: Look at my successful ones.
Lucia: 你那个啥
Lucia: What about yours?
Lucia: 这个要很小心的
Lucia: You have to be very careful with this.
Alice:这点够吗
Alice: Is this enough?
Jake:还行吧
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:感觉碰到了一下问题不大
Jake: It seems like it touched a bit, but it's not a big deal.
Lucia: 我解决问题的方式回避问题
Lucia: My way of solving problems is to avoid them.
Jake:我来给你跟拍
Jake: I'll film you.
Tasha: 把这个还是拿到楼上冰箱冷藏
Tasha: Let's take this upstairs to the fridge to chill.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Lucia: 好的 10分钟吗
Lucia: Okay, 10 minutes?
Tasha: OK对
Tasha: Yes, that's right.
Jake:那要不
Jake: How about...
Tasha: 就等这边完事了
Tasha: Let's wait until we're done here.
Tasha: 那边就可以开始了
Tasha: Then we can start over there.
Lucia: 行好的
Lucia: Alright, sounds good.
Lucia: 看看这这能放下不
Lucia: Let's see if this can fit.
Lucia: 这好哎
Lucia: This is nice.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Lucia: 算了还是放楼上吧
Lucia: Forget it, let's put it upstairs.
Tasha: 这可以吗
Tasha: 这可以也可以
Lucia: 这如果要放的话
Lucia: 就得把这架子重新倒腾一下
Lucia: 我看看楼上吧
Lucia: 如果楼上东西不多的话应该能放下
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Yeah?
Shure: 你是不是有酒精来着
Shure: Do you have any alcohol?
Lucia: 我没有酒精
Lucia: I don't have any alcohol.
Lucia: 我只有碘伏
Lucia: I only have iodine.
Shure: 啊那那那记
Shure: Ah, well, that won't...
Shure: 我们最高度数的酒就是朗姆了
Shure: The highest proof alcohol we have is rum.
Shure: 那也不够烧的
Shure: Even that's not enough to burn.
Jake:咋整呢
Jake: What should we do?
Shure: 再搞一次吧
Shure: Let's try again.
Shure: 运送火种
Shure: Transport the flame.
Jake:给你挡着有用吗
Jake: Is it useful if I block it for you?
Jake:有点用吗
Jake: Does it help a bit?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这就先放楼下吧
Lucia: Let's leave it downstairs for now.
Lucia: 要不然楼上放不下了
Lucia: Otherwise, it won't fit upstairs.
Lucia: 呃靠
Lucia: Ugh, shoot.
Lucia: 楼下也放不下
Lucia: It doesn't fit downstairs either.
Shure: 对我们可以把线
Shure: Yeah, we can put the wire...
Jake:直接点
Jake:直接放进去点
Lucia: 呃好
Lucia: 有任何需要搭把手的
Tasha: 呃伯爵红茶
Tasha: Uh, Earl Grey tea.
Tasha: 芒果再搞点芒果吧
Tasha: Mango, let's add some more mango.
Katrina: 哇那个我们学校卖可贵了
Katrina: Wow, it's super expensive at our school.
Alice:直接拿炭烧吧
Alice: Just burn the charcoal directly.
Lucia: 碳让它燃起来
Lucia: Let the charcoal burn.
Lucia: 是不是得花点钱
Lucia: Does it cost a bit?
Lucia: 给先放点容易燃的东西之类的
Lucia: Put some easily flammable stuff first.
Alice:是他那个就是易燃物比较少
Alice: There's just not much flammable material.
Alice:就直接用碳吧
Alice: Just use charcoal directly.
Alice:反正守着煤气罐呢
Alice: Anyway, we're right by the gas tank.
Alice:的通好风
Alice: Ventilate well.
Alice:别一会给大家整一氧化碳中毒了
Alice: Don't want everyone getting carbon monoxide poisoning.
Lucia: 不会的
Lucia: It won't happen.
Shure: 哦这样也行
Shure: Oh, that works too.
Shure: 那边着了
Shure: It's lit over there.
Shure: 应该没事
Shure: It should be fine.
Jake:着了着了火了火了
Jake: It's lit, it's on fire, it's on fire.
Shure: 着了着
Shure: It's lit.
Shure: 了着了
Shure: 可以了走吧
Shure: It's good, let's go.
Shure: 我说那边着了已经
Shure: I said that place is already on fire.
Shure: 他也着了
Shure: He's on fire too.
Jake:咋吃呢
Jake: How do we eat this?
Lucia: 嗯一般来说你得拿个勺挖着吃
Lucia: Well, generally, you need to use a spoon to scoop it.
Lucia: 但这个装蜂蜜的勺已经被我征用了
Lucia: But I've already used the honey spoon.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以在这种情况下
Jake: So in this situation...
Alice:你可以跟我一样用筷子吃
Alice: You can use chopsticks like me.
Jake:我找找看
Jake: I'll see if I can find some.
Lucia: 对所以你就可以考虑用筷子吃
Lucia: Yeah, so you can consider using chopsticks.
Tasha: 八十克
Tasha: 80 grams.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Jake:我再想想
Jake: I'll think about it.
Lucia: 咱们那个一次性的那个勺还还在吗
Lucia: Do we still have that disposable spoon?
Jake:我觉得在感觉是我放哪去了
Jake: I think we do. I feel like I put it somewhere.
Lucia: 为什么民宿里会没勺
Lucia: Why would there be no spoons in the guesthouse?
Lucia: 总感觉有哪里怪怪的
Lucia: It feels a bit strange.
Lucia: 应该有才对
Lucia: There should be some.
Lucia: 让我看看有没有什么别的原料
Lucia: Let me see if there are other materials.
Lucia: 给您做一个
Lucia: I'll make one for you.
Lucia: 充当一下
Lucia: To substitute.
Lucia: 鉴定完毕没有
Lucia: Are you done identifying it?
Tasha: 哦多了再煮一会
Tasha: Oh, it's too much. Let it cook a bit longer.
Jake:难搞不定
Jake: It's difficult, not sure.
Jake:算了
Jake: Forget it.
Jake:硬核
Jake: Hardcore.
Lucia: 啊这有这有点大
Lucia: Ah, this is a bit big.
Lucia: 洗一下吧
Lucia: Let's wash it.
Lucia: 这个好没咋用过
Lucia: This one hasn't been used much.
Jake:我我已经喝我已经喝到了
Jake: I, I already drank it, I already drank it.
Jake:我觉得挺好的
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:就当就就硬喝就
Jake: Just drink it straight, just drink it.
Lucia: 哈哈你确定吗
Lucia: Haha, are you sure?
Lucia: 筷子也不需要来一个吗
Lucia: Don't you need a pair of chopsticks?
Jake:不用了不用了挺好的
Jake: No, no, it's pretty good.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright then.
Jake:这啥呀这怎么做的呀
Jake: What is this, how is it made?
Jake:用鸡精调的呀
Jake: Is it seasoned with chicken essence?
Tasha: 嗯真的
Tasha: Hmm, really.
Jake:真的真的吼吼
Jake: Really, really.
Jake:我看看你的小本本
Jake: Let me see your notebook.
Jake:红茶包红茶包
Jake: Black tea bag, black tea bag.
Jake:哪来的买的
Jake: Where did you buy it?
Tasha: 买的
Tasha: Bought it.
Tasha: 你觉得哪来的
Tasha: Where do you think it's from?
Jake:买的
Jake: Bought it.
Tasha: 林涵好聪明
Tasha: Lin Han is so smart.
Shure: 加大火势
Shure: Increase the heat.
Katrina: 这个这个东西好用吗
Katrina: Is this thing useful?
Katrina: 晚上玩火要尿床的
Alice:晚上玩火会怎么尿床
Alice: What happens if you play with fire at night?
Katrina: 尿床
Katrina: Bedwetting.
Shure: 尿炕
Shure: Wetting the bed.
Lucia: 哇这是什么味道
Lucia: Wow, what's that smell?
Katrina: 是楼下那个烧炭火的
Katrina: It's the charcoal burning from downstairs.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 我发现我衣服一直都没拿上来
Lucia: I realized I haven't brought my clothes up yet.
Lucia: 随便撂个地方吧
Lucia: Just leave them anywhere.
Lucia: 早晨的这个水要倒掉
Lucia: You need to pour out this morning's water.
Lucia: 这个这个应该是新杯哎
Lucia: This should be a new cup.
Lucia: 这这几个呢
Lucia: What about these?
Katrina: 写字了吗
Lucia: 我感觉没有
Lucia: I don't think so.
Katrina: 没写字那就是可以的
Lucia: 这应该也是新杯子
Lucia: This should also be a new cup.
Lucia: 嗯感觉可以
Lucia: Yeah, feels okay.
Lucia: 因为我们一会如果要倒饮料就可以倒
Lucia: Because if we pour drinks later, we can use it.
Lucia: 剩下这些是大家用过的
Lucia: These are the ones everyone has used.
Tasha: 就是这么烧出来的
Tasha: That's how it's cooked.
Tasha: 呃好可以是
Tasha: Uh, okay, sure.
Tasha: 完了又少了
Tasha: Oh no, it's missing again
Jake:那咋办
Jake: Then what should we do?
Tasha: 少了没有办法
Tasha: There's nothing we can do if it's missing
Tasha: 味道浓一些
Tasha: Make the flavor stronger
Jake:你上回说的你要搞
Jake: Last time you said you wanted to do it
Jake:几个这种彩票款
Jake: A few of those lottery-style ones
Jake:你不是说想搞几个彩票款
Jake: Didn't you say you wanted to do a few lottery-style ones?
Jake:彩票款吗
Jake: Lottery-style ones?
Jake:看谁能吃到
Jake: See who can get it
Tasha: 算了呃那个打蛋器呃盆
Tasha: Forget it, uh, that egg beater, uh, bowl
Tasha: 对就是那个盆啊
Tasha: Yes, that bowl
Lucia: 呃上次用的那个
Lucia: Uh, the one we used last time
Tasha: 就是你刚冷冻起来的那个
Tasha: The one you just froze
Lucia: 哦get it
Lucia: Oh, got it
Tasha: 哎还有一个呢
Tasha: Hey, there's another one
Alice:经过我们的不懈努力
Alice: After our relentless efforts
Katrina: 明天就跳跳舞是吧
Katrina: So we're just dancing tomorrow, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Katrina: 然后明天要压花了
Katrina: And pressing flowers tomorrow
Katrina: 要不然来不及
Katrina: Otherwise, we won't make it in time
Jake:压压花跳跳舞划划水
Jake: Press flowers, dance, and swim
Katrina: 对对对明天买
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, buy it tomorrow
Tasha: 少了一个这个
Tasha: Missing one of these
Katrina: 明天买下美文纸和旺仔牛
Katrina: Tomorrow, buy beautiful paper and Wangzai milk
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:做做早饭
Jake: Make some breakfast.
Lucia: 哎奇怪我找找看
Lucia: Hmm, strange. Let me check.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯有没有可能
Lucia: Hmm, is it possible...
Katrina: 几天我想想
Katrina: Let me think.
Jake:等快递整整理整理
Jake: Wait for the delivery and organize things.
Katrina: 明天是星期五了
Katrina: Tomorrow is Friday.
Lucia: 在在在在楼上呢
Lucia: It's upstairs.
Jake:明天星期五了
Jake: Tomorrow is Friday.
Jake:星期六整理整理拿到了
Jake: Organize it on Saturday and get it.
Lucia: 这个不是吧
Lucia: This isn't it, right?
Katrina: 那今天晚上就
Katrina: Then tonight...
Katrina: 明天必须压了
Katrina: We have to press it tomorrow.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Katrina: 那我等会压一下
Katrina: I'll press it later.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 楼家要是没有我就再上楼看一下
Lucia: If it's not in the house, I'll check upstairs again.
Katrina: 时间过得可真快
Katrina: Time flies.
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 嗯啊好的
Lucia: Hmm, alright.
Jake:划划水就划完了
Jake: Just paddle through.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Shure: 我们有特别特别高浓度的酒精吗
Shure: Do we have any very high-concentration alcohol?
Jake:特别
Jake: Very.
Jake:特别高的
Jake: Very high.
Katrina: 特别特别的
Katrina: Very, very.
Shure: 浓度的酒精
Shure: High-concentration alcohol.
Jake:多高啊要干啥
Jake: How high? What for?
Shure: 75那种
Shure: Like 75%.
Lucia: 助燃吧
Lucia: Add some fuel.
Shure: 对就是助燃
Shure: Yes, just add fuel.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:烧不起来是吧
Jake: It won't burn, right?
Jake:喝完了还行
Jake: After drinking, it's okay.
Lucia: 还挺干净
Lucia: It's quite clean.
Lucia: 来我帮你
Lucia: Let me help you.
Jake:还行
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 我我刚好帮你洗了
Lucia: I just happened to wash it for you.
Jake:哦谢谢你
Jake: Oh, thank you.
Lucia: 因为我这个也要洗
Lucia: Because I need to wash this too.
Jake:那我看看火去
Jake: Then I'll check the fire.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 总感觉这勺子可以留一下
Lucia: I feel like this ladle can stay.
Lucia: 要不放旁边吧
Lucia: How about putting it aside?
Tasha: 可以帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me?
Lucia: 嗯你说
Lucia: Yes, go ahead.
Tasha: and 0.5的茶
Tasha: and 0.5 of tea.
Tasha: 3个蛋黄
Tasha: 3 egg yolks.
Lucia: 这个碗里没有油就是好洗
Lucia: This bowl is easy to clean since there's no oil.
Tasha: 75克柠檬
Tasha: 75 grams of lemon.
Lucia: 15克糖
Lucia: 15 grams of sugar.
Lucia: 是按一下清零
Lucia: 放上去按一下清铃是吗
Lucia: Put it on and press to reset, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: 好了吗哦
Tasha: Is it done? Oh.
Lucia: 还没好
Lucia: Not yet.
Lucia: 是75克吗
Lucia: Is it 75 grams?
Tasha: 先到20 呃先到21.7
Tasha: First to 20, uh, first to 21.7.
Lucia: 现在21.7克
Lucia: Now it's 21.7 grams.
Tasha: 呃因为我要先加
Tasha: Uh, because I need to add first.
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: A little more.
Tasha: 低呃算了
Tasha: Uh, forget it.
Tasha: 快到吧
Tasha: Almost there.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 这是不是有点太小了
Tasha: Isn't this a bit too small?
Lucia: 有可能我们要不倒多少
Lucia: Maybe we should pour some out.
Tasha: 分两次
Tasha: In two parts.
Lucia: 然后取对取下来再那个什么
Lucia: Then take it out and, you know...
Lucia: 你是刚好要加两次吗
Lucia: Are you adding it twice?
Tasha: 我要加三次
Tasha: I need to add it three times.
Tasha: 那你倒35克先
Tasha: So you pour 35 grams first.
Tasha: 然后剩下的你再倒35
Tasha: Then the remaining 35 grams.
Lucia: 34.8可以吗
Lucia: Is 34.8 okay?
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 要在这里面
Lucia: It needs to be in here.
Lucia: 在在家吗
Lucia: Are you at home?
Jake:他说8:50就到了
Jake: He said he would be here by 8:50.
Alice:我刚才是应该是
Alice: I was just...
Lucia: 刚才是35
Lucia: It was 35 just now.
Tasha: 三十五
Tasha: Thirty-five.
Lucia: 那这个这个是要到多少
Lucia: So, how much does this need to be?
Katrina: 那这个这个啊
Katrina: So this, this...
Tasha: 四十啊
Tasha: Forty.
Lucia: 直接到40啊
Lucia: Directly to 40?
Shure: 心如过来今晚上
Shure: Xinru is coming over tonight.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:我也要玩啊
Jake: I want to play too.
Lucia: 40克
Lucia: 40 grams.
Jake:打发是吧
Jake: Whipped, right?
Tasha: 好你来
Tasha: Okay, you do it.
Jake:好你从哪找这样的
Jake: Okay, where did you find this?
Lucia: 26.8
Lucia: 26.8.
Jake:另一个啊
Jake: Another one.
Jake:另一个那个
Jake: That other one.
Jake:哎少在这小的
Jake: Hey, don't mess with the small ones.
Tasha: 你猜
Tasha: You guess.
Lucia: 29.9
Lucia: 29.9.
Jake:凑30是吗
Jake: Rounding to 30, right?
Tasha: 40啊
Tasha: Forty.
Lucia: 40差不多
Lucia: Forty, about right.
Tasha: 好差不多来
Tasha: Okay, almost there.
Lucia: 外面那点不管他
Lucia: Don't worry about that bit outside.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:这么多数字我用几
Jake: So many numbers, which one do I use?
Tasha: 拉到最大就行哎呦
Tasha: Just turn it all the way up.
Jake:哈哈哈你不是说拉到最大就行
Jake: Hahaha, didn't you say to turn it all the way up?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你猜
Lucia: Hahaha, guess what?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 好好来吧
Tasha: Alright, let's do it.
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: Me.
Lucia: 你猜我那天裤子上奶油是怎么奔上的
Lucia: Guess how the cream got on my pants that day?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 来吧
Tasha: Come on.
Jake:有点突然
Jake: A bit sudden.
Tasha: 雨露均沾一下
Tasha: Share the rain evenly.
Jake:好哎好玩
Jake: Alright, this is fun.
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan.
Shure: 你是不是住这个楼上
Shure: Do you live upstairs?
Shure: 就是阳阁楼上
Shure: Upstairs in the attic.
Shure: 你把那个窗户关上
Shure: Can you close that window?
Katrina: 窗户关上
Katrina: Close the window.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Tasha: 好那就那就30克吧
Tasha: 那加3次要加85克
Lucia: 行稍等二九点啊
Lucia: 再来一点
Lucia: Add a bit more
Lucia: 耶刚好
Lucia: Yay, perfect
Shure: 我妈远程通过看我这色
Shure: 告诉我什么放的少了
Katrina: 你妈这能看出来
Katrina: Your mom can see that?
Katrina: 你刚那平板的充电宝呢
Katrina: Where's the charger for that tablet?
Jake:哦哦哦你妈给你指导的是吧
Jake: Oh, your mom is guiding you remotely?
Lucia: 第二回放多少 20还是25
Lucia: How much for the second time, 20 or 25?
Jake:哦可以可以
Jake: Oh, that's neat
Tasha: 都可以只要最后一共是85就行
Tasha: Either is fine as long as the total is 85
Lucia: 一共85 刚才30啊
Lucia: A total of 85, we had 30 just now
Jake:能放油吗
Jake: Can we add oil?
Lucia: 那还差50
Lucia: We're still 50 short.
Jake:你这个火
Jake: This fire...
Lucia: 那就那就2525行吗
Lucia: How about 2525, is that okay?
Shure: 油肯定不能放吧
Shure: We definitely can't add oil, right?
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: We can.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:助然嘛
Jake: Naturally.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Katrina: 你妈说烧烤粉放少了
Katrina: Your mom said we didn't put enough BBQ seasoning.
Alice:什么这么呛
Alice: Why is it so smoky?
Shure: 他说好看着
Shure: He said it's fine, just watch.
Shure: 因为正常好像他说是要放酱油的
Shure: Because normally, he said we should add soy sauce.
Shure: 但是我忘记有这个
Shure: But I forgot about that.
Shure: 对然后就是靠酱油带带
Shure: Yeah, and then we rely on the soy sauce for color.
Jake:那就那还能
Jake: So, can we still...
Jake:还能救吗
Jake: Can we save it?
Shure: 不是一个是带色
Shure: It's not just for color.
Shure: 再一个就是咸味嘛
Shure: Also for the salty taste.
Katrina: 咸味嘛
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 那就补补点这个呗
Shure: So let's just add some more of this.
Jake:补点吧可以
Jake: Add some, sure.
Lucia: 24.9
Jake:来上酱油
Jake: Let's add soy sauce.
Shure: 酱油没有
Shure: We don't have any soy sauce.
Shure: 咱们我以为不用
Shure: I thought we didn't need it.
Shure: 所以我就没买你知道吗
Shure: So I didn't buy any, you know?
Jake:那咋办呢放点盐
Jake: So what do we do? Add some salt?
Shure: 没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 就是缺缺这个
Shure: We're just missing this.
Shure: 就补了点烧烤料就差不多
Shure: Just add some BBQ seasoning, it should be okay.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Jake:低配版问题不大
Jake: The low-cost version isn't a big deal.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:为最后一天准备是吧
Jake: Preparing for the last day, right?
Shure: 80%还原了已经
Shure: We've already restored 80%.
Shure: 货不货
Shure: Is it done?
Lucia: 24.8行吗差的不OK
Lucia: 24.8, is that okay? We're still not quite there.
Shure: 还有那个
Shure: And that one
Shure: OK
Lucia: 哇这个低筋粉用的还蛮快的咦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, this low-gluten flour is being used up quite fast, haha.
Shure: 那个一会记得也呼了一下
Shure: Remember to give that a call later.
Shure: 我再去看外面看看火
Shure: I'll go outside and check the fire.
Shure: 好火彻底灭了
Shure: Alright, the fire is completely out.
Shure: 哦你问问管家
Shure: Oh, ask the housekeeper.
Jake:一点火星都不剩
Jake: Not a single spark left.
Shure: 管家能不能帮忙送个酒精啥的
Shure: Can the housekeeper help us get some alcohol?
Shure: 应该有你快问一下酒精啥的
Shure: There should be some, ask quickly about the alcohol.
Jake:要啥
Shure: 反正最后一天也得用
Shure: We'll need it for the last day anyway.
Shure: 你问问管家有没有酒精
Shure: Ask the housekeeper if there's any alcohol.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Is that so?
Shure: 那个到哪了瞅一眼
Shure: Where did it go? Take a look.
Shure: OK 9分钟39就能吃上了
Shure: OK, in 9 minutes and 39 seconds, it'll be ready to eat.
Shure: 能吃上吧
Shure: Ready to eat, right?
Jake:蛋糕能吃上
Tasha: 蛋糕不能吃上
Lucia: 烤的时间比较久是吗
Lucia: Does it take a long time to bake?
Tasha: 对呀
Lucia: 哇这个这个
Lucia: Wow, this, this
Lucia: 好像我爸每次炒的牛肉
Lucia: Looks like the beef my dad cooks every time.
Lucia: 他就会拌成这样
Lucia: He always mixes it like this.
Lucia: 非常非常像
Lucia: It looks exactly the same.
Tasha: 茶包哎
Tasha: Tea bag, hey.
Tasha: 我刚拿了吗
Tasha: Did I just take it?
Lucia: 饿了哈哈哈饿了
Lucia: I'm hungry, haha, hungry.
Alice:好想下手抓一抓
Alice: I really want to grab a bit.
Tasha: 然后加哦
Tasha: Then add, oh
Tasha: 植物油植物油
Tasha: Vegetable oil, vegetable oil.
Tasha: 哎哎这呢
Tasha: Hey, hey, here it is.
Jake:这叫伯爵奶茶是吗
Jake: Is this called Earl Grey milk tea?
Tasha: 油呢油呢哎油呢
Tasha: Oil, oil, hey, where's the oil?
Tasha: 哎这谁拿到这的
Tasha: Hey, who put this here?
Alice:每件浅色衣服都逃不过
Alice: Every light-colored piece of clothing can't escape.
Shure: 拿点
Shure: Take some.
Tasha: 好能把搅一下吗
Tasha: Alright, can you stir it?
Tasha: 就是拿筷子搅一下
Tasha: Just use chopsticks to stir it.
Shure: 厨房湿巾在哪
Shure: Where are the kitchen wipes?
Shure: 楼上吗
Shure: Upstairs?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 等一下我那个
Lucia: Wait a second, my...
Lucia: 呃餐巾纸我拿一张
Lucia: Uh, I'll grab a napkin.
Lucia: 要不然筷子板上来又没事
Lucia: Or else, if the chopsticks come up, it's fine.
Lucia: 等一下还没搅完
Lucia: Wait a second, it's not stirred yet.
Lucia: 搞完再弄一下
Lucia: Finish it, then stir it again.
Lucia: 是要大概搅到啥程度呀
Lucia: How much should we stir it approximately?
Tasha: 融合就行
Tasha: Just until it's blended.
Tasha: 没关系这里面还会再融的
Tasha: It's okay, it will blend more in here.
Lucia: 啊这俩要要要融合可能要
Lucia: Ah, these two need to blend, might need to...
Shure: 把那个一会烤架给擦一下
Shure: Wipe the grill a bit later.
Jake:这好融啊
Jake: This blends easily.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Okay, done.
Lucia: 哈哈先把牛顿
Lucia: Haha, first get Newton...
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么融化
Jake: Hahaha, how does this melt?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 但是这个这个原理是牛顿发现的
Lucia: But this principle was discovered by Newton.
Jake:不管他不管不管
Jake: Doesn't matter, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 不管他反正对
Lucia: Doesn't matter, anyway, yeah.
Jake:反正物理有物理的问题
Jake: Anyway, physics has its own problems.
Tasha: 物理学不存在
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 生物学有关的问题都归到牛顿头上
Lucia: All the biology problems are attributed to Newton.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 你要来搅拌吗有没有人
Lucia: 我来
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 怎么搅
Tasha: 就搅就行了
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 应该没有问题了
Tasha: It should be fine now.
Jake:那为什么不能用他的那个一
Jake: So why can't we use his one?
Jake:他不是有好几档吗
Jake: Doesn't he have several settings?
Tasha: 是的你真的很聪明
Tasha: Yes, you are really smart.
Tasha: 要不你来
Tasha: How about you do it?
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no!
Tasha: 这是切蛋糕的
Alice:大的小的
Alice: Big ones or small ones?
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Jake:这是切蛋糕的
Jake: This is for cutting the cake.
Lucia: 呃对那天微微解释一下他怎么用的
Lucia: Uh, right, that day Tasha explained how to use it.
Lucia: 但是其实我也没搞明白
Lucia: But honestly, I didn't quite get it.
Lucia: 反正总之就是这样用的
Lucia: Anyway, that's how it's used.
Jake:什么时候切
Jake: When do we cut it?
Tasha: 等会就切
Tasha: We'll cut it in a bit.
Tasha: 你要切吗
Tasha: Do you want to cut it?
Jake:我要切
Jake: I want to cut it.
Tasha: 好你切
Tasha: Okay, you cut it.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我想象不出来
Jake: I can't imagine it.
Jake:一点都想象不出来
Jake: I really can't imagine it at all.
Tasha: 你能帮我扶一下
Tasha: Can you hold this for me?
Tasha: 从这开始
Tasha: Start from here.
Lucia: 这个大概搅成什么样呀
Lucia: What should this be stirred to look like?
Tasha: 就这样就行了
Tasha: Just like this, it's fine.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 只不过我这边还在压模具
Tasha: But I'm still pressing the mold here.
Lucia: 嗯那我趁你压的时候接着搅搅
Lucia: Okay, I'll keep stirring while you press.
Tasha: 压的不好看
Tasha: The pressing doesn't look good.
Tasha: 不过没关系
Tasha: But it's okay.
Tasha: 我不想认真叠它了就这样
Tasha: I don't want to stack it neatly, just like this.
Tasha: 什么你来好了呀
Tasha: What? You do it then.
Tasha: 要越高越好
Tasha: The higher, the better.
Tasha: 因为这样子可以减少它的气泡
Tasha: Because that way it can reduce the bubbles.
Tasha: 据说是这样子
Tasha: That's what they say.
Tasha: 不知道做了几个人的量
Tasha: I don't know how many people's workload this is.
Jake:这就整完了
Jake: It's all done.
Jake:就剩烤了
Jake: Just need to bake it.
Jake:这是预热过的
Jake: This is preheated.
Jake:烤40分钟
Jake: Bake it for 40 minutes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:就等着就行了嗯
Jake: Just wait for it, yeah.
Tasha: 然后再打发个奶油就行
Tasha: Then whip some cream and it's done.
Tasha: 但是奶油打发等它快烤出来再打就行
Tasha: But whip the cream when it's almost done baking.
Shure: 咱们最后一天是周一还是周日来着
Shure: Is our last day Monday or Sunday?
Jake:周日哎
Jake: Sunday, yeah.
Jake:周周一周日搞完活动周一
Jake: We finish the event on Sunday, and on Monday...
Shure: 还要复盘吗
Jake:呃划划水
Jake: We'll just take it easy.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Jake:复个盘拆屋子
Jake: Review and dismantle the setup.
Tasha: 我们结束了
Tasha: We're done.
Jake:把屋子拆了
Jake: Take down the setup.
Tasha: 这个还要小
Tasha: This one still needs to be smaller.
Tasha: 没事了
Tasha: It's fine now.
Tasha: 这个洗了等会打奶油用
Tasha: This is washed, we'll use it to whip the cream later.
Alice:我洗个筷子
Alice: I'll wash some chopsticks.
Tasha: 嗯应该是吧
Tasha: Hmm, should be.
Alice:去上个厕所
Alice: Going to the bathroom.
Alice:先放一下
Alice: Just leave it here for now.
Shure: 然后可以布置布置桌子了
Shure: Then we can set up the table
Shure: 准备准备吃了
Shure: Get ready to eat
Katrina: 去外面是吗
Katrina: Go outside, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:半毛半毛新币
Jake: Half a new coin
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it
Jake:5毛新币
Jake: 50 cents new coin
Lucia: 不记得了
Lucia: Can't remember
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure: 不行我也饿了得赶紧
Shure: No, I'm hungry too, let's hurry
Lucia: 但是你可以试试看
Lucia: But you can try
Jake:简单的快乐
Jake: Simple happiness
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Tasha: 然后你把蛋糕放在这
Tasha: And then you put the cake here
Tasha: 然后这样子过去
Tasha: And then move it like this
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 好等会你来展示
Tasha: Good, you'll demonstrate later
Jake:好的交给我吧
Jake: Sure, leave it to me
Jake:我先切一个土豆试一试
Jake: I'll cut a potato first to try
Tasha: 如果说你们想要切三层对吧
Tasha: If you want to cut three layers, right?
Tasha: 那那你可能就要在第一层
Tasha: Then you might need to do the first layer
Tasha: 第三层和最上面一层
Tasha: The third layer and the top layer
Jake:嗯没问题
Jake: No problem
Tasha: 这样子就可以切出来
Tasha: Then you can cut it out
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem
Jake:我先试试
Jake: I'll try first
Tasha: 不是还要加芒果吗
Tasha: Aren't you adding mango?
Tasha: 然后我们可以一层芒果夹心
Tasha: Then we can have a mango layer
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 一层奶油夹心
Tasha: A layer of cream filling.
Katrina: 啊好好吃
Katrina: Ah, it's so delicious.
Tasha: 然后一层草莓夹心等等
Tasha: Then a layer of strawberry filling and so on.
Jake:然后一层
Jake: And then a layer...
Jake:哦好好好
Jake: Oh, okay, okay.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah!
Jake:怎么做啊
Jake: How do we do it?
Jake:那就切草莓
Jake: Then let's slice the strawberries.
Jake:切芒果的是吧
Jake: Slice the mangoes, right?
Tasha: 你不是说尽量把芒果消灭掉吗
Tasha: Didn't you say we should get rid of the mangoes as much as possible?
Jake:就是就是把它切成碎
Jake: Yes, just chop them into small pieces.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah!
Tasha: 豆和巧克力豆夹心夹层
Tasha: Bean and chocolate chip layers.
Tasha: 所以大家要吃什么夹层
Tasha: So, what layer do you all want to eat?
Tasha: 就夹什么夹层就行了
Tasha: Just add whatever layers you like.
Katrina: 天好幸福
Katrina: Oh, this is so blissful.
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow.
Katrina: 芒果的芒
Katrina: Mango, mango.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: That's quite impressive.
Jake:芒果在这
Jake: The mango is here.
Jake:我要怎么准备它
Jake: How do I prepare it?
Tasha: 把皮削了
Tasha: Peel it.
Tasha: 然后你如果想吃大块的你就不切
Tasha: And if you want to eat big pieces, don't cut it.
Tasha: 就直接一片一片的加进去
Tasha: Just add it slice by slice directly.
Jake:好我先去拿个酒精
Jake: Okay, I'll go get some alcohol first.
Tasha: 如果你想吃芒果丁你就全部都切成丁
Tasha: If you want mango cubes, just cut it all into cubes.
Shure: 我还没叫呢
Shure: I haven't ordered yet.
Jake:好嘞好好好没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, no problem.
Tasha: 敷衍
Tasha: You're so perfunctory.
Jake:哎你好
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:好来了来了来了嘿
Jake: Okay, coming, coming, hey!
Tasha: 嗯我要吃肉哈哈
Tasha: Hmm, I want to eat meat, haha.
Lucia: 那等一下
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 他们应该很快就可以考了
Lucia: They should be able to finish soon.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 一个蛋糕会不会太少了要不要在烤店
Tasha: Is one cake too little? Should we bake more?
Tasha: 纸杯的反正也很简单
Tasha: Cupcakes are pretty simple anyway.
Lucia: 都可以你决定
Lucia: Anything's fine, you decide.
Tasha: 所以那天的量是10个的量
Tasha: So the amount that day was for 10.
Tasha: 所以还是考10个就行了
Tasha: So we just bake 10 again.
Tasha: 超级简单这个
Tasha: This is super easy.
Lucia: 也可以如果如果
Lucia: Also, if we...
Lucia: 今天晚上吃不
Lucia: If we don't finish it tonight,
Lucia: 完的话
Lucia: we can
Lucia: 冷藏到明天早上当早饭也可以是吗
Lucia: refrigerate it and have it for breakfast tomorrow, right?
Tasha: 可以吧
Tasha: That should be fine.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Great!
Lucia: 不会那个什么
Lucia: It won't...
Tasha: 嗯应该可以吧
Tasha: Yeah, it should be okay.
Tasha: 那只需要把这个擦干就行了
Tasha: We just need to dry this off.
Tasha: 然后我们嗯
Tasha: And then we...
Tasha: 完全看不见他的状态
Tasha: I can't see its condition at all.
Tasha: 我干错了我挑战一下他
Tasha: I messed up, I'll challenge him.
Tasha: 他已经
Tasha: He already...
Lucia: 哦这个太挨着上面了是吗
Lucia: Oh, this is too close to the top, right?
Tasha: 对所以哎呀完了有一张纸掉上去了
Tasha: Yeah, so... Oh no, a piece of paper fell on it.
Lucia: 拿筷子剪出来行吗
Lucia: Can we use chopsticks to pick it up?
Tasha: 嗯可以我就感觉他太靠上了
Tasha: Yeah, I just feel it's too high up.
Lucia: 哎刚刚用的那根筷子上哪去
Lucia: Where did the chopsticks we just used go?
Tasha: 所以想要挑
Tasha: So, you want to...
Lucia: 是不是已经被洗了
Lucia: Were they already washed?
Lucia: 擦一下
Lucia: Wipe it off.
Lucia: 要不要把底下这层撤了
Lucia: Should we remove the bottom layer?
Lucia: 然后光放一层
Lucia: Then just put one layer
Tasha: 对我刚刚想的也是把它放在
Tasha: Yeah, I was just thinking to put it on
Tasha: 蛋糕雏形
Tasha: The cake shape
Lucia: 拆一下
Lucia: Take it apart
Tasha: OK
Lucia: 多么甜蜜
Lucia: How sweet
Tasha: 擦干就行
Tasha: Just dry it off
Tasha: 继续准备一下原材料
Tasha: Keep preparing the raw materials
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my God
Tasha: 我去我军手套只有最后一双了不戴了
Tasha: Oh no, my military gloves, it's the last pair, not wearing it
Jake:密码也只要7天就
Jake: The password will only last 7 days
Shure: 对 3天才能记住
Shure: Yeah, it takes 3 days to remember
Lucia: 好像可以了
Lucia: Seems like it's ready.
Jake:我来切哦
Jake: I'll cut it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:圣火来了
Alice: The sacred fire is here.
Shure: 慢慢慢慢来慢慢来
Shure: Slowly, slowly, take it slow.
Shure: 再慢点再慢点再慢点OK
Shure: Even slower, even slower. OK.
Shure: 稳住稳住
Shure: Steady, steady.
Shure: 给他立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Katrina: 你最擅长
Katrina: You're the best at this.
Shure: 立起来点
Shure: Lift it up a bit.
Jake:哎是为什么要打奶油是吗
Jake: Hey, why are we whipping cream?
Katrina: 哎是来
Katrina: Hey, come on.
Lucia: 哎这个是还没洗是吧
Lucia: Hey, is this not washed yet?
Lucia: 这个不用洗不用洗
Lucia: This doesn't need washing.
Tasha: 这个不用洗因为他还是放蛋黄
Tasha: This doesn't need washing because it still has egg yolk.
Katrina: 因为他还是放弹幕嘛
Katrina: Because it still has egg yolk.
Lucia: 哦行
Lucia: Oh, alright.
Tasha: 让你打3个蛋你怎
Tasha: I told you to beat three eggs, how did you...
Jake:这样好不行啊
Jake: This way is not good.
Lucia: 补充点能量才能打得好
Lucia: Add some energy, then you can beat it well.
Jake:对对对打蛋得费劲呢
Jake: Yes, yes, beating eggs is hard work.
Jake:打了打了
Jake: Beating, beating.
Tasha: 这呢这呢
Tasha: Here, here.
Jake:对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 无菌手套不够了不戴了我洗干净
Tasha: No more sterile gloves, I'll just wash my hands.
Lucia: 幸
Lucia: Fortunately...
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Good.
Tasha: 好好好好好
Tasha: Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Katrina: 好好好
Katrina: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 他盖着盖子
Lucia: He's covering it.
Alice:不对不许来水了
Alice: No, no water this time.
Alice:不对不许来风了
Alice: No, no wind this time.
Jake:嗯好谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, thanks.
Lucia: 哇好厉害啊
Lucia: Wow, that's awesome.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 打蛋是一门学问你学不来
Tasha: Cracking eggs is an art, you can't learn it.
Lucia: 对我学不来哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, I can't learn it, haha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 我学不来
Tasha: I can't learn it.
Tasha: 我替他在说这句话
Tasha: I'm speaking for him.
Tasha: the next
Tasha: The next.
Jake:哎我觉得
Jake: Hey, I think...
Lucia: 再再来一个是吧
Lucia: Another one, right?
Jake:哈哈哈我觉得还有两个赞嘛
Jake: Haha, I think we still have two more likes.
Lucia: 我来
Lucia: I'll do it.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Lucia: 专注气氛组一万年
Lucia: Focus on the atmosphere team for ten thousand years.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 你这个会磕太厉害了
Lucia: You're knocking it too hard.
Lucia: 小心哇这都没了哈哈
Lucia: Be careful, wow, it's all gone, haha.
Jake:没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 天选打单人
Lucia: Chosen one goes solo
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake:是这是逐步探索边界
Jake: Yes, this is gradually exploring the boundaries
Katrina: 人
Katrina: Man
Lucia: 他刚才超级强的磕了一下竟然弄没了
Lucia: He just hit it super hard and it disappeared
Katrina: 我也听到了
Katrina: I heard it too
Katrina: 我也会烂在手上
Katrina: I'll mess it up too
Tasha: 这个这个这个放到那个冷藏yes
Tasha: This, this, this, put it in the fridge, yes
Lucia: 对OK
Lucia: Right, okay
Lucia: 看一眼那可能还是得放到楼上去
Lucia: Take a look, maybe we should put it upstairs
Tasha: 你可以把这个没事你去吧
Tasha: You can take this, it's okay, go ahead
Lucia: 这个这个放在哪
Lucia: Where should I put this?
Lucia: 这已经擦好了
Lucia: This is already cleaned
Tasha: 呃干的就放在这就行我觉得
Tasha: Uh, just put the dry ones here, I think
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay
Jake:哎真好看
Jake: Hey, it looks nice
Tasha: 这个擦一下这个
Tasha: Wipe this, wipe this
Jake:谁
Jake: Who?
Jake:这个好
Jake: This is good
Jake:哇起火了
Jake: Wow, it's on fire
Jake:哇好开心
Jake: Wow, so happy
Jake:看一眼烤一烤
Jake: Take a look, roast it
Shure: 酒精烧完了他都没烧吧
Shure: The alcohol burned out but it didn't burn, right?
Shure: 完了完了
Shure: It's over, it's over.
Jake:完了原来是纸的
Jake: It's over, turns out it's paper.
Alice:不耐烧
Alice: Not fire-resistant.
Jake:纸在烧我以为碳全烧起来了
Jake: The paper is burning, I thought all the charcoal was burning.
Shure: 他们确实烧起来了
Shure: They really are burning.
Jake:哦小烧起
Jake: Oh, a small fire started.
Tasha: 他怎么洗着洗着碗跑了呢
Tasha: How did he run off while washing dishes?
Lucia: 呃那是要洗啥呀我来
Lucia: Uh, what needs washing? I'll do it.
Tasha: 这个洗干擦干就行
Tasha: Just wash and dry this, it'll be fine.
Katrina: which are reconnecting
Lucia: 洗
Lucia: Wash.
Shure: 拿一下
Shure: 你们现在都是古希腊掌管圣火的女神
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 这是酒精吗哪来的
Katrina: Is this alcohol? Where did it come from?
Shure: 他们应该是都着了这个碳
Shure: 累死了妈妈
Shure: So tired, mom.
Katrina: 我来吧
Jake:怎么说
Jake:怎么灭了呀
Alice:那个小的呢
Alice: Where's that kid?
Alice:你那个酒精呢
Alice:还有一点点火
Alice: There's still a little fire.
Jake:酒精都快用完了
Jake:可以今天一个失败的尝试明天可以继续烤
Jake:今晚吃蛋糕吧
Katrina: 我要吃一块披萨
Katrina: I want to eat a piece of pizza.
Jake:还不行
Jake: Not yet.
Tasha: 啊嗯
Tasha: Ah, um.
Tasha: 好了好了好了
Tasha: 来吧放在这里这里
Tasha: Come on, put it here, here.
Jake:放在哪里
Tasha: 这里
Tasha: 然后继续搅
Tasha: Then keep stirring.
Tasha: 对对不我说等会继续搅
Tasha: Yes, yes. No, I mean keep stirring later.
Tasha: 是不是应该换个大点
Tasha: Should we switch to a bigger one?
Jake:这个是要做什么
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha: 这个这个就做第2种甜品
Tasha: This, this is for making the second dessert.
Tasha: 就纸杯蛋糕呀
Tasha: It's just a cupcake.
Tasha: 可以爆浆
Tasha: It can have a filling inside.
Shure: 不行我就把这个一起放进去
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:给他弄灭了吧
Alice: Put it out for him.
Katrina: 帅
Katrina: Cool.
Katrina: 像魔术师一样
Katrina: Like a magician.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 好搞笑啊
Katrina: So funny.
Katrina: 特别是他在那打蛋
Alice:等一下你到最后一点
Alice: Wait, at the very end.
Alice:给你照个相
Alice: I'll take a picture of you.
Jake:有用吗
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Alice:等等等稍等一下
Alice: Wait, wait, hold on a second.
Jake:看起来有用
Katrina: 特别像在表演魔术
Katrina: It really looks like he's performing magic.
Shure: 你一定要刷的帅一下
Shure: You have to make it look cool.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Jake:要变出一个人出来
Shure: 大火中谢斌竹晃出来
Jake:边上是不是着了
Jake:没了
Shure: 没了
Jake:怎么办
Jake:也可以想了不少办法
Jake:要不我整点电脑来助助兴
Alice:烧点硬盘
Alice: Burn the hard drive.
Jake:对烧点盘
Shure: 他们都只红了一点点
Shure: They only turned a little red.
Jake:烧点显卡
Alice:有个小夹呢
Alice: Where's the small clip?
Shure: 这烧的快这呼一下就着了
Shure: 看今天是8000美金先报还是我们先吃上饭好吗
Alice:不在那边一会那个火星泼你身上
Alice: Don't stay over there, the sparks might hit you.
Katrina: 这么难这么难燃烧
Katrina: So hard, so hard.
Shure: 人生没有容易二字懂了吗
Katrina: 听的感动了
Shure: 这时候现在知道谁是盘中餐粒粒皆辛苦了吧
Shure: 其实它有温度
Katrina: 哦还没给我妈打视频呢
Shure: 你妈妈说你快远离这个是非之地吧
Katrina: 我妈不接呀
Shure: 你妈妈不爱你了
Katrina: 我妈妈不要你了
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi
Katrina: 喂
Katrina: Hello
其他人：你是戴了个眼镜吗
Katrina: 对呀
其他人：你能看到什么东西啊
Katrina: 我不能看到什么
Katrina: I can't see anything
Katrina: 我就是戴了一个普通的眼镜而已
Katrina: I'm just wearing regular glasses
Katrina: 给你看我们在干嘛
Katrina: Let me show you what we're doing
Katrina: 我们在点火
Katrina: We're lighting a fire
其他人：自己搞烧烤啊
Katrina: 因为我们要烤肉吃
Katrina: Because we want to barbecue
Katrina: 但是我们的火一直没起来
Katrina: But our fire won't start
Alice:我觉得可以上烤盘了
Katrina: 特别可怜
Katrina: It's so pathetic
Alice:烧的还挺热的
Katrina: 这是我们的房间
Katrina: This is our room
Katrina: 他们在这吃
Katrina: They are eating here
Katrina: 他们在做甜品
Katrina: They're making desserts
Katrina: 给你看呀
其他人：这是啥
Katrina: 这是做的蛋糕
Katrina: This is the cake we made
Katrina: 看到没
Katrina: 我们今天又去
Katrina: We went out again today
Katrina: 超市了
Katrina: To the supermarket
Katrina: 这我们买的东西
Katrina: These are the things we bought
Katrina: 我们戴眼镜就算干活了呀
Katrina: Just wearing glasses counts as working
Katrina: 是我们每天的
Katrina: It's our daily routine
Katrina: 今天午饭
Katrina: 去公园去买烤肉
Katrina: Go to the park and buy barbecue
Katrina: 排骨没了
Katrina: The ribs are gone
Lucia: 所以咱奶油应该是一会才用吧
Tasha: 嗯等蛋糕烤好的吧
Katrina: 这是做纸杯蛋糕吗
Katrina: Are these for making cupcakes?
Tasha: 嗯做两种蛋糕
Tasha: Yeah, making two kinds of cakes
Tasha: 因为感嗯太闲了
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Tasha: 感觉外面
Tasha: It feels like outside
Katrina: 外面的火还没起来呢
Katrina: The fire outside hasn't started yet
Tasha: 还没起来
Tasha: Not yet
Katrina: 他那个炭烧不着
Katrina: The charcoal won't light up
Katrina: 学了呀我今天还学了
Katrina: I'm learning, I learned it today